I won't have to pay off place to
continually story the Academy Awards
we're about to answer the question whose
hard work paid off was the Best
Supporting Actor of the year to give it
to us I give you a lady who doesn't need
any support miss Angela Lansbury
as usual Academy members have nominated
five talented men for this coveted award
they are Stanley Holloway in my fair
lady Peter Ustinov in topkapi Edmund
O'Brien in seven days in May Lee Tracy
in the best man Sir John Gielgud in
Beckett
the winner in Peter Ustinov in
accepting more Peter Ustinov mr.
Jonathan winter
I don't know whether Peter expected this
I certainly didn't sure to wear black
socks
make this very brief I'm more excited
than the computer we're here himself
he's in England I'm pretty sure in
Europe I obviously isn't here but if he
were here I'm sure would be almost as
beaches as me that's about it thank you
so much on behalf of the Academy and
Industry and everything I hope that
covers everybody